welcome to the show i have some
interesting clips to play for you
some very important stories to discuss
and one of the biggest areas of concern
that's really
it's really turned into kind of a mask
off moment for much of the american
right and the trumpian right is the
degree to which
all sorts of people have been just
falling all over themselves to defend
kyle rittenhouse the shooter in kenosha
wisconsin and you might remember that
last week tucker carlson sort of
defended the vigilantism
of kyle rittenhouse and more recently
tucker carlson interviewed one of the
attorneys for kyle rittenhouse
i'm going to tell you about some of the
other attorneys momentarily it's quite a
cast of characters
but when interviewed this um
attorney essentially turned this
into praise for what an accurate
marksman and how controlled
the behavior of kyle rittenhouse was
that he didn't shoot
more people given the situation if you
follow what his attorney says here
given the situation a lesser i was going
to say a lesser man
a lesser kid would have maybe shot
even more people than kyle rittenhouse
did so check this out and by the way
we're going to get to this but
it turns out that rittenhouse's other
lawyer
so i'm gonna play video of john pierce
kyle rittenhouse's other lawyer
appears to be a q anon conspiracy
theorist
like every detail is insane but let's
start with attorney john pierce talking
about what kyle rittenhouse did
is just amazing you know kyle the only
individuals that
that kyle shot were the three
individuals that were attacking him
and putting him at risk of serious
bodily harm or death
this is a 17 year old kid this is this
is amazing
so let me ask you this and i think
that's a that's a fair point he didn't
shoot indiscriminately and in
i'm taking your word for it in the first
one because i haven't seen the video but
in the second two i have seen the video
one guy attacked and the other guy it's
um it's it's amazing
what he did what what does that even
mean
amazing is not the word that i think of
like it's amazing he didn't shoot
more people is that the argument is that
an argument that you could
make with a straight face in a court of
law
uh and i want to reverse reverse the
framing just
just for a second here um you are going
to see them
actually portray part of they've shown
some of their cards
they are going to try to portray kyle
rittenhouse
as a law abiding militia dude who was
merely keeping the peace
they're going to try to make this 17
year old who is too young
to even be carrying a gun in this way in
wisconsin legally
they're going to try to make him into
the good samaritan
because he was out there helping he was
helping
out there and of course this actually to
some degree reminds me
of the george zimmerman scenario with
trayvon martin
where when a vigilante claims
self-defense
it's like a bank robber robber saying
the teller got aggressive
during the bank robbery or like george
zimmerman
saying i had to defend myself in a
confrontation with trayvon martin
which i created by being a
cop wannabe in my neighborhood watch
group
or whatever it was it was that he was
doing years ago so
that's attorney john pierce saying it's
amazing this guy's a hero rather than a
criminal
then we have the other lawyer one of the
other lawyers for kyle rittenhouse
who's completely out of his mind um i'm
talking about
lynn wood lynn wood is part of a
an organization called the fight back
foundation
which is about using lawsuits
to stop the lies and smears of the
radical left
and lynnwood said on twitter that the
fightback foundation is going to be
funding kyle rittenhouse's defense team
they've got donors holding this kid up
as a hero and funding his defense team
and lynnwood's twitter profile has the
hashtag
wwg1wga
you might be wondering what the hell is
that it's a q anon thing
and it stands for where we go one we go
all it's a line from the 1996 jeff
bridges
uh sailing adventure white squall
which they miss a tribute to president
kennedy it's crazy but it's a q anon
uh hashtag and i mean you know
step back for a moment what better way
to make these killings into political
events
than to have a political organization
represent the killer that's effectively
what these lawyers are
pierce the attorney i played a clip of
earlier
was put on leave from his law firm then
called pierce bainbridge
beck price and hect after a report found
that he was accepting money from a
lender for personal use
and uh supposedly it was four million
dollars
a month before he was put on leave there
was a lawsuit from a former partner
accusing employees of the company of
financial and sexual misconduct as well
as sexual assault i mean it's like
there's just no depth to the depravity
of
everybody involved in this situation and
he's being
represented kyle rittenhouse is by a
group
who are as shady as you would expect
in a situation like this where they seem
to be seeing this
more as an opportunity for
self-promotion than to good than an
opportunity to do
good legal work um i
now i guess i should mention
there's a good chance they're going to
be able to muddy this up
in the process of defending kyle
rittenhouse his lawyer
lynn wood is saying you know he didn't
actually transport the gun across state
lines he got it from a friend
as if that's a defense of course that
means the friend committed a felony by
giving a gun to someone under 18.
he then aided and abetted uh by by
loaning that gun
kyle rittenhouse of course was illegally
in possession of that firearm in the
state of wisconsin it's illegal for
anyone under 18 to have a weapon in
wisconsin even though it's an open carry
state
kid should have known that but he didn't
and pay
attention to that and killed two people
so there's a lot of really ugly stuff
here that's not even being mentioned but
they are trying to and partially
succeeding at
turning this kid into a hero and people
are donating to his legal defense fund
the lawyers are out of their minds and
this could be
i mean listen the justice system needs
to work its way
work its process but there's already
some really ugly red flags going on here
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch and i've put that link right
underneath this video